it is often said that all of
quote-unquote Western thought is simply
footnotes to Plato and this is both of
course somewhat hyperbolical and at the
same time cannot chew but the man
himself can't of course take all the
credit because indeed there have been
few schools of thought as influential on
our world on the some of the greatest
religions and thinkers in history as the
philosophical School of neoplatonism
appearing in late Antiquity as a
continuation of the school of platonism
neoplatonism would come to play a
decisive role in the philosophy and
Theology of Christianity Islam Judaism
and really all of Western thought as we
sometimes call it indeed the category
that we often call mysticism is almost
entirely based in its language and and
symbolism on the school called
neoplatonism it's a topic that has come
up a lot in our previous discussions in
previous episodes on this channel and
will continue to do so in the future so
I think it's high time that we ask
ourselves the question what actually is
neoplatonism
[Music]
I'm very happy and honored to say that
this episode is part of a large
collaborative project with some of my
friends and colleagues here on YouTube
some truly amazing people and Scholars
that are making some incredible content
this collaboration includes zevi from
Seekers of unity who will be covering
neoplatonism and its relationship with
Kabbalah both the origins of Kabbalah in
terms of how neoplatonism plays a role
there as well as the periods of medieval
times and the Renaissance Dr Justin
Sledge from the channel esoterica will
be covering neoplatonism and its
relationship with gnosticism
Dr Angela Pucca from Angela's Symposium
will be covering platinus and eamblicus
two of the most Central figures in early
neoplatonism and their views on Magic in
particular we also have Dana trell
who'll be covering Thomas Taylor's
platonist Creed an incredibly
interesting text and lastly we also have
John verveiki who will be making an
episode covering neoplatonism and its
relationship with cognitive science so
this is a massive large collaborative
project that all are sort of trying to
get at the topic of neoplatonism from
different angles and in relationship
with different Traditions from now from
around the world so be sure to check out
the episodes by all these other amazing
people and you'll get a wide and and
comprehensive understanding of
neoplatonism from different perspectives
which I think is really valuable
neoplatonism is one of the most
influential philosophical movements ever
and the clues to its place in
intellectual history are right there in
the name neoplatonism
it is in other words a form of platonism
the tradition that follows and builds on
the teachings of Plato
and this is an important Point platonism
can be a broad category and we often
divide it into periods and schools like
middle platonism and indeed neoplatonism
or late platonism but we should remember
that they are all parts of a single
Tradition at least in a sense according
to these philosophers themselves they
all saw themselves as simply adhering to
when clarifying the teachings of their
Master Plato
the word neoplatonism is therefore often
seen as somewhat problematic by Scholars
it's not a word used by its adherence so
you'll never hear the ancient new
platonists call themselves neoplatonists
but this is rather a modern
anachronistic term used by Scholars and
historians the term Neo means new which
seems to indicate that this was a new
philosophy but to the neoplatonists
there was nothing new about it it was
simply the true interpretation of the
ancient platonic teachings therefore
many scholars as well as myself to some
degree often prefer to use other terms
like late platonism to refer to this
movement in order to highlight that it
was not some new separate thing but a
late stage of development for the
platonic school of thought and also to
some of the girls for a late stage of
development for all of Greek and
Hellenic philosophy in general
furthermore we should probably not look
at neoplatonism as a school at all
because that's 2 is a modern academic
construct many of the thinkers we
categorize as neoplatonist can differ in
dramatic ways as we will see
so we should keep in mind that this is a
general term used to denote a late stage
Pagan platonism which has certain
characteristic features that unify it
but which also can be incredibly diverse
and complicated in any case it's clear
that neoplatonism was very Innovative
and has features that set it apart from
earlier representatives of platonism in
general
so with that said what is it then that
makes neoplatonism neoplatonism well the
movement or School basically originated
in the third Century with an amazing
figure called platinus
he is usually described as the
quote-unquote founder of neoplatonism
and many of its characteristic teachings
can be traced to him even though he
would say that he actually takes them
directly from Plato of course platinus
is one of the most fascinating
incredible and indeed influential
philosophers of all time and to
understand neoplatonism we kind of need
to understand him even though the school
was further developed and associated
with successive figures like porphry
iamblicus and proclus plutanus is kind
of the man in this case so it serves as
well to explore him a bit more in depth
platinus lived in the third Century as I
mentioned he was from Alexandria in
Egypt originally but was deeply
hellenized and spent most of his career
as as a philosopher in the city of Rome
he was well respected and famous during
his lifetime and we know of his ideas
and teachings primarily through his
writings a collection of treatises
compiled by his student portfrey known
as the eniads and will return to this
work later but this is important because
basically all we know about platinus is
life comes from a short biography that
porphy included as a kind of prologue to
the iniads and which is called simply on
the life of platinus in other words it
is the story of plutonis's life as
viewed from one of his own students but
despite its brevity this account
contains some truly amazing details as I
already mentioned he was born in Egypt
around the year 204 and grew up in the
city of Alexandria in particular
porfree tells us that platinus was very
secretive about his background and
disliked talking about it so we don't
really know much at all about his early
years but sometime in his late 20s he
became interested in philosophy and
started studying in Alexandria under a
teacher called ammonius sakas
porfree tells us that patina studied
under ammonius with two other students
arenius and origen
and you may recognize that later name
because it is the name of one of the
most famous early Christian philosophers
and theologians
he was also from Alexandria and so both
the name the time and the place seem to
suggest that this might be the same guy
in other words platinus and the famous
origin might have been School buddies
although the scholars continue to
disagree about his true identity many
believe that there may have been two
Origins and that this is simply a
coincidence that this name shows up here
in the life of plutonus as well in any
case porphy also tells us that all the
students of ammonias were forced to
promise never to reveal his teachings to
others a promise that none of them seems
to have kept because after traveling
around the Mediterranean world for a
while platana settled in the city of
Rome when he was around 40 years old and
quickly became famous as a great
philosopher that attracted many students
he really became the philosopher of the
third century and especially an
authority on Plato and platonism no one
could explain Plato better than platinus
and he was the preeminent scholar of
platony's Doctrine in the world at the
time he certainly seems to have been a
very charismatic figure judging from
these stories about his life in some
ways he adopted a kind of
semi-pythagorean Lifestyle for example
by living a rather ascetic life not
eating very much and following a
strictly vegetarian diet
people from all walks of life from
Senators to people of the lower classes
both men and women would attend his
lectures and hold them in great regard
and there was a kind of inner circle of
close students which included porphyrie
who wrote this biography there are
incredible stories about patanus's
supposed spiritual powers and Status he
of course lived in a world that was
entirely dominated by the classical
religion of a Greece and Rome and he
seems to have respected that religion to
some degree because we don't find any
evidence in his writings that he was at
all openly critical to the cult but at
the same time he seems to have seen
himself as being somewhat above those
kinds of things what he was doing was
philosophy right exploring the higher
noetic realities and not these
relatively lower practices associated
with religion in one of the more
dramatic and striking parts of porphy's
biography he tells us of one time when
platina said something that
was quite shocking to the people around
him quote emilius was fond of sacrifices
and used to busy himself with rights of
the new moon and rights to La fears
he once tried to get titanus to
participate with him but platina said
they must come to me not I to them
we do not know what consideration led
him to make such a grand pronouncement
and did not have the nerve to ask him
as we can see from this quote even
portray himself and the rest of the crew
seemed quite shocked by this seemingly
Empire statement saying that the gods of
the religious Pantheon should come to
him rather than the other way around to
the point that they didn't have the
nerve to inquire about it anymore
another story tells of how another
philosopher Olympus of Alexandria was
jealous of platinus and wanted to use
magic to basically cast a spell and
attack him
but once he did he realized that
platinus's Soul was so powerful that all
the attacks simply deflected back onto
Olympus himself forcing him to give up
the Tinus had cultivated his soul and
noetic Consciousness so much that it was
a force to be reckoned with lastly we
can't recount patanus's life without
mentioning the story about the summoning
of his Guardian Diamond porphy tells us
that there was an Egyptian priest that
came to visit Rome and wanted to
demonstrate his powers by inviting
platinus so that he could summon his
protective Diamond so at this time it
was believed that each person had a
protective diamond and intermediary
Spirit between humans and gods and this
priest from Egypt could supposedly
summon these diamonds for free recount
the event thus quotes platinus readily
agreed and the invocation took place in
the temple of Isis since the Egyptians
said that this was the only pure place
he could find in Rome when he called
upon the titanus's diamond to appear it
was a God that came rather than a member
of the genus of diamonds as the
Egyptians said you are blessed since you
have a God as your diamond and are not
accompanied by a member of the lower
genus
in any case the fact that patinas was
accompanied by a diamond of superior
Divinity led him to raise his god-like
vision towards it this is why he wrote
the book on our allotted diamond in
which he tries to explain why different
people have different Guardians again we
see here an example of titanus's
impressive spiritual Powers his personal
Diamond was not just some old regular
Diamond but an actual God but despite
these very lofty details he was also
just a guy and is described as being
very pleasant kind and caring as an
individual
indeed many people especially those who
were about to die wouldn't trust their
children to his care and his house was
quote filled with boys and girls whom he
looked after and cared for
So Not only was he an incredibly
well-respected philosopher but also kind
of a well-respected person in general in
his Society perhaps unsurprisingly given
the fact that our information comes from
a devoted disciple he's also described
as rather Pleasant to look at we do have
depictions of platinus even though he
personally refused to be painted or
sculpted saying quote isn't it enough
that I have to carry around the image
that nature is clothed me with like a
true platonist he believed that
everything in the visible world
including our bodies are only imperfect
images or copies or reflections of the
perfect world of forms in the news so to
paint an image or make a sculpture of
him would be to paint an even more
imperfect image of an already imperfect
image and he wasn't about that porphy
tells us that they cheated though and
got a famous painter and sculptor to
attend to tennis lectures and memorize
his looks so that he could later
recreate it thus we have depictions that
are supposedly pretty close to real life
platanus sadly was sick for a lot of his
life having a lot of problems with his
bowels and became Afflicted with nasty
throat infections which in the year 270
when he was 66 years old finally
resulted in his passing
the greatest philosopher of his day and
one of the most significant thinkers in
world history breathed his last with the
words quote try to elevate the God
within us to the Divine in the universe
titanus's Legacy is incredibly vast and
we are lucky that basically all of his
philosophical writings survive and after
his death our friend porphry decided to
take all of those treatises and compile
them into a single albeit incredibly
messy collection still a magnificent
work of philosophy which became known as
the any ads
any AD means a group of nine and the
work essentially consists of 54
treatises divided into six any ads that
is six groups of nine treatises each
Division and structure is entirely by
porphyry and is really weird it divides
single treatises into many and has a
pretty confusing outline based on a
loose kind of thematic structure
nonetheless this work would come to play
a major role in the history of
philosophy and religion sometimes under
other names and in misattributed forms
which we'll touch on in future episodes
but it is in these any ads that we find
the teachings of platinus and therefore
also the foundational ideas of late
platonism or neoplatonism so what is
this guy all about well it's worth
pointing out once again that patina
simply sees himself as clarifying and
explicating the teachings of Plato
so the contents of his neoplatonic
philosophy is based strongly on the
platonic dialogues and incorporates many
of the characteristic thoughts of Plato
such as the world of forms for example
he seems especially interested and
influenced by some specific dialogue
such as for example the Parmenides where
we get ideas about the one and which is
often seen as Plato's most mature and
complex metaphysical dialogue and also
very importantly for those of you who
know your Plato you'll know that he had
quite an esoteric side and that he
famously dissed the whole project of
writing Philosophy for this reason there
is often talk about Plato's so-called
Unwritten doctrines those ideas that he
never wrote down but which represents
his true deepest ideas
and this wasn't some later invention
either as Aristotle himself one of
Plato's students affirmed that these
Unwritten doctrines were a thing and
gibbs's hints as to what they were
actually about without going too deeply
into it we can say that it seemed like
these secret true doctrines were
strongly related to ideas associated
with pythagoreanism such as a huge
emphasis on the idea that the
foundations of reality is based on a
monad and a dyad a one and a successive
two esoteric number metaphysics in other
words and platina seems to be influenced
and claims to represent and teach these
Unwritten doctrines this is unsurprising
when we consider the fact that the very
core of his philosophy consists of the
idea of the one which we'll get to soon
so he bases his philosophy on Plato on
his dialogues the unwritten doctrines
and the platonic tradition that
developed afterwards so platanus follows
in a strong and flourishing tradition of
wisdom which include not only platonism
but also other schools such as stoicism
he really was the philosopher of his day
as we said
and despite how much he wants to claim
that he is simply relaying the teachings
of Plato there is no denying that he was
incredibly Innovative and original
himself but this is why neoplatonism is
such a significant school of thought and
school of philosophy it's kind of the
culmination of the whole project of
Hellenic philosophy patanus takes
inspiration from from the platonic
tradition from Plato but also certain
aspects from from Aristotle the
peripatetic philosophy he also takes
certain aspects of stoicism and it
creates this incredible
system if we can call that a system this
incredible philosophy that we now know
as neoplatonism it's it's really
significant and really really important
stuff it's really difficult to know
where to begin when it comes to
neoplatonism but in the most General
Strokes we can say that it is a
philosophy that conceives of different
levels of reality these levels or real
realities perhaps being referred to as
hypotheses in the original Greek
at the core of this entire system at the
core of reality itself and it's you
could say its highest level is the
concept of the one tohen in Greek
the one is completely Beyond any
description or understanding it's beyond
being it's beyond time and space it is
one but it's also not one because
calling it one is actually saying too
much this is a radically apathetic
principle something that lies completely
beyond the light of human understanding
and its Concepts but it is from this one
and kind of also in this one that
everything else unfolds we will return
to the incredible way that platinus
describes or perhaps undescribes the one
in the enniads later but it is in short
an utter Simplicity from which
everything else emanates
it's also identified with the platonic
concept of the good and the Beautiful
and these three terms are sometimes used
interchangeably to refer to this one
concept of the one now basically
everything I say here is going to have
to be nuanced and maybe even redacted
later on but will begin with a simple
overview
from this one there is a kind of
emanation something appears which is
distinct from the one but is
simultaneously kind of the same at the
same time
the one is so perfect that it overflows
into something other than itself in a
sense
a perfect image of the one which is
called the news
is a word in Greek that is basically
impossible to translate and I really
mean that this time the most common
translation is perhaps intellect but we
also see other words or translations
like mind sometimes Divine mind or
Consciousness none of which really
captures its full meaning so we're just
going to be using the word news from
here on out the news is the first
principle after the one it's a kind of
Consciousness in which knowledge about
everything is contained
the nose is still Beyond time and space
so it is a mind that knows all things at
the same time so to say and in a unified
way all its knowledge is a single it's
it's a single thing right it's not that
it has knowledge of all these separate
things in different times it has
knowledge of everything but that
knowledge is a completely unified
knowledge of everything in a single
Eternal instant you could say the news
is one it's an utter Unity that is
numerically singular perhaps even more
properly called one than the actual one
which is as we said even beyond the
concept of Oneness
it is the lower the known and the act of
knowing all in one and everything is
contained in the news in complete Unity
it is this news that is the platonic
world of forms that the archetype of the
whole world but as a Unity Beyond
temporality and distinction
the news is being itself the news is
even God now sometimes platinus will
refer to the one as God but more often
it is the news that represents the
concept that we associate with God most
of the time so to use more theological
or theistic language than platinus
himself would have been comfortable with
the news is God and the forms are God's
Own thoughts as he knows himself
with a knowledge that is identical to
himself this news not only contemplates
itself but also looks back at the one
and contemplates this one even though
this is technically impossible and as a
result of this there is then another
emanation we move sort of further away
from the one as there appears another
lesser reality and this is the soul or
piche in Greek
the soul receives the information stored
in the intellect and is sort of
responsible for taking all that
knowledge and making it into actual
stuff just like the nose looks back at
the one its originator the soul looks
back at the nose its originator and
contemplates it and as a result it
emanates or creates the universe as we
know it the world of Multiplicity the
world of things of time and space which
is often referred to as the world of
nature it is here below the level of
soul that everything we know and
experience in the sensible world exist
including our own individual Souls the
sensible world is kind of the outer
manifestation or imperfect copy of the
perfect noose and its contents which is
the world of forms everything we
experience here exists in the news in a
more perfect and unified Way Beyond
temporality so this is a pretty neat and
understandable system right it begins at
the top with the one which emanates the
news which emanates the soul which in
turn emanates or creates the
the physical world as we know it makes
total sense right
wrong in fact while the outline that
I've just given is accurate in a sense
it can also be very misleading and even
lead to inaccurate understandings and
interpretations of late platonist
metaphysics for one thing this whole
process of emanation takes place outside
of time
when we think of this process of being
or becoming we see it as the one
becoming the Noose becoming the soul but
this implies a temporal progression
which is not how it should be understood
time doesn't exist except in the level
below Seoul in our sensible universe so
this whole process from the one to the
nose to the soul is not something that
happens quote unquote or even has
happened it is a description of the way
reality is in the Eternal non-temporal
moment it recounts an essential
structure within reality not an event it
can be pretty trippy to wrap your head
around but it is important not to
conceive of this as a temporal thing of
something happening in a in time and
space secondly we describe this process
as one thing kind of creating another
and in our minds we often imagine these
realities as being different or
separated from each other in some way in
a kind of hierarchy the one is way up
here and the material world is somewhere
down here and they are as far away from
each other as they can be but this can
also be very misleading while platinus
does point out that there is a
difference between the one and the news
and the news and the soul and he's
actually pretty strict about this and in
one way and in certain passages they are
also in some way part of a single
reality forget this vertical image that
I presented and instead imagine all of
reality including these levels and the
physical Universe unfolding within the
Noose itself and ultimately within the
one itself this is more of a monistic
picture and the different levels are all
a single reality or a kind of Continuum
you could say perhaps a better image
would be to see them as circles within
each other but even that is a compromise
because after all this process or these
hypotheses can really be
imagined in a kind of in in the sense of
a kind of image or a representation
really it is a metaphysical reality
Beyond time and space we can't really
imagine what it's like for example at
least according to platinus the human
self down here on Earth is not separated
from the noetic world that is the world
of the news or even from the one
actually the individuals South is in the
news right now and at all times we are
all constantly participating in the news
and even in the one we are the news and
we are the one even if we don't realize
it so you can see that this neat
division into various levels or
realities is very misleading because it
is also a deeply integrated system where
there is a distinct continuity between
the lowest and highest aspects of
reality it's all taking place within
itself so to say and this is important
for another reason namely that
platinus's philosophy and really most of
neoplatonism is very much performative
and participatory in nature it's not
just some abstract theoretical
philosophy about the way that reality is
structured but also involves the process
by which the individual person can
realize his true nature his true self by
climbing up this ladder of existence
back from this lower parts of the
physical universe and the body all the
way back up to the Noose on the human
level patanus tells us that we are to
turn away from our bodies matter is seen
as evil in a sense but only in so far as
it becomes an object of desire as
opposed to the one or the good indeed to
platinus the one is present even in
matter itself and the physical world is
a beautiful yet imperfect copy of the
noetic world of forms so platanus's
practical instructions involve a shift
of focus from the bodily and material to
the intellectual
we are to detach ourselves from the
desires of the physical and instead turn
towards our higher self which has its
home in the noetic world in other words
this involves a kind of asceticism not
an extreme one by any means but
certainly a way of living that is
tempered and controlled
titanus himself seems to have lived a
rather aesthetic life eating relatively
little and when he did eat it was
exclusively a vegetarian diet
some neoplatanists have opted to live a
life of sexual abstinence altogether but
this was not something required or the
norm really in general patanus tells us
that we are to make the journey inward
into the depths of our own selves and to
again turn away from the bodily and
contemplate our true noetic self and the
higher realities how on does this on a
more concrete level is hard to say some
have speculated that platinus may have
performed some sort of meditation
practice and taught this kind of
practice to students but this is
uncertain and mostly speculation it
seems pretty certain that it involves
some sort of inward traveling might of
traveling inwards into the soul and the
depths of the self and through that sort
of Ascend higher into the to the noetic
and the intellectual worlds and when she
does that she can realize her true home
in the nurse and in a sense even become
United with the news or more accurately
to realize that she was The Noose the
entire time further more platanus even
seems to indicate that we can become
mystically United with the one itself to
experience a quote Flight of the alone
to the alone or a solitary in the
solitary as platina says himself in the
very final words of the enyads you can
perhaps see why many have chosen to call
platanus a Mystic when we take all these
aspects into account now words like
Mystic and mysticism are of course
debated and problematic in some way but
I think it's important to recognize and
consider this very participatory aspect
of titanus's teachings and the teachings
of neapolitanism because it is a very
Central aspect of their philosophy like
I said it's not only about the structure
of reality in a theoretical sense but
the human Journey back to her higher
Essence a kind of spiritual
self-realization and Ascent back to the
source there's a bi-directional
progression everything flows from the
one and ultimately returns back to it
like inhaling exhaling of breath this
language and imagery has become some of
the most influential and recurring in
the history of the category of mysticism
across various religions and spiritual
Traditions ever since then this motion
of flowing out and returning is a core
feature of neoplatonism the human
being's true home is in the news and
this outer bodily form is only a
fleeting temporary shell The World Isn't
inherently negative though indeed
platinus has a whole Treatise in the
anions called against the gnostics where
he basically tears this group of early
Christians apart very basically they
believe that the physical world was
created by an evil demiurge or false
queer God and that basically all of the
world is a kind of negative prison and
platanus did not agree with this idea he
does not have as negative of a view of
the physical world and of creation as
such and so he dedicates this Treatise
in the an ads to complete refuting the
gnostics sometimes very harshly after
all the world is a copy of the perfect
news but in a kind of imperfect way
remember the nose contains everything
that is and ever will be in this world
but in a non-temporal and perfect way
we are experiencing that world in an
imperfect way through the mediation of
time and space and at the same time we
also saw everything takes place in the
news we are all in the news right now
and having these experiences inside the
noetic world this is a world view that
is fundamentally different from the
modern one most of us hold where we
conceive of a real external world out
there outside of our subjective Minds
the neoplatonic view is sort of the
other way around completely there isn't
a real external World in which there are
Minds the external world is in fact
within mind within news or consciousness
it's not that the external world isn't
real at least as we commonly understand
that phrase but simply that mind or news
is the prior principle it is
consciousness or news that is real and
the external World unfolds within that
Consciousness but there is still a kind
of hierarchy right this physical world
is less perfect than the world of the
news and this is why platinus and the
other neoplatonists put such an emphasis
on leaving the body right of ascending
back towards the higher world or I
should say the higher aspect of the
world or reality because like I said
it's all a single Continuum in a sense
now here is another good opportunity to
stop and dispel some possible
misunderstandings and sort of wrong ways
of imagining this stuff when we say that
the soul leaves the body and travels up
into the higher noetic worlds one
tendency to imagine this is to think of
the Soul as sort of leaving the body and
somehow sort of traveling up and to
space or something all the way up there
that is not how this should be
understood this whole journey the
Journey of the Soul into the higher
realms
all of it takes place inside oneself
right it's a it's a journey inward not
upward into some some Heavenly world
right it's a it's a it's a journey
inward into the depths of the Soul into
the depths of the self because it is
there inside ourselves in our true sort
of essence our true core that is where
the news and maybe even the one actually
is so to say it is within us that this
entire Cosmos exists from nature to Soul
to news remember we are in the nose we
are the nose so the entire nomadic
reality including knowledge of all
things and the whole of reality exist
within the self there are depths to the
South that very few people have any idea
of and this journey of ascent is the
process of realizing this aspect of
yourself this is what time it refers to
as the undescended soul or the
undescended self that there is a true
part of ourselves that is always in the
news and never leaves it quote the fact
is that even our own soul does not
descend in its entirety but there is
something of it always in the
intelligible world
however if that part which is in the
sensible World becomes dominant or
rather if it is dominated and subjected
to disturbance it does not permit there
to be self-awareness in us of that of
which the upper part of the soul is in
contemplation this idea of the
undescended self is a Core teaching of
platinus in particular but it should be
pointed out that many later
neoplatonists indeed some of the most
prominent ones like ayamblicus and
proclus all completely disagreed with
him on this topic the doctrine of the
understand itself was entirely rejected
by a many later near platonists once One
lets go of all feathers of physical body
and existence and plunges into the
depths of one's true self the human
becomes United with the news
platinus himself very famously describes
the experience of this journey from the
body and the bafflement of having
actually returned from the non-temporal
noetic experience of the absolute back
to his regular old body and individual
Consciousness he says quote often after
waking up to myself from the body that
is externalizing myself in relation to
all other things while entering into
myself I behold the beauty of wondrous
quality and believe then that I am most
to be identified with my better part
that I enjoy the best quality of life
and have become United with the Divine
and situated within it actualizing
myself at that level and situating
myself above all else in the
intelligible World following on this
repos within the Divine and descending
from intellect into acts of calculative
reasoning I ask myself in bewilderment
how on Earth did I ever come down here
and however did my soul come to be
enclosed in a body being such as it has
been revealed itself to be even while in
a body this return seems to be the
highest experience or state that a
person can strive towards but platina
sometimes goes even further and suggests
that the person can even become the one
itself
this is a very complicated topic and
patanus doesn't talk about it as much as
he does about the news primarily because
well it can't be talked about
in fact an experience of becoming the
one or mystically uniting with the one
is not an experience at all it's beyond
even experience the one is after all
covered by an absolute apathetic
Darkness nothing can be said about it it
lies in the utter darkness of unsaying
and unknowing Beyond things like
understanding description or even
experience as we saw the way that
platinus approaches describing or
talking about the one in the anions is
absolutely incredible it's a sort of
exercise in trying to explain something
that cannot be explained or talked about
in these texts we find some of the most
radical and amazing examples of
apathetic philosophy and expression in
history he will describe the one in a
certain way in multiple passages and
then later on completely contradict
himself the one is one but the one is
not one the one is free and then the one
is not free in fact what is so
fascinating about this approach is that
it isn't necessarily descriptive at all
that is platinus is not describing
anything about the one for us because
such a thing cannot be achieved instead
it's a kind of participatory process
what does this mean well when platanus
describes or rather undes describes the
one he's taking us on a journey or a
kind of exercise
he doesn't give us any actual
descriptions of the one but gives us
paradoxical statements the one is this
but it is not this the one is that but
also not that he's helping us collapse
all our conceptions and understandings
undermining any way that we can
conceptualize the topic in our head
until there is nothing left but our own
unknowing or ignorance and it is there
in that unknowing darkness that we maybe
will get a glimpse of what the one
entails
it's crazy stuff and it is this one that
we can become one with as it were
we've already explored the fact that
everything kind of takes place within
the one and everything partakes of the
one although this is another one of
those paradoxes the one is everything
and everywhere but it is also nowhere
and utterly beyond anything quote it is
because the one is omnipresent for there
is nowhere where it is not and so it
fills everything and so it is a mini or
rather it is already all things for if
it itself we're only everywhere it would
be everything but since it is also
nowhere while all things come to be due
to it because it is everywhere they are
other than it because it is nowhere
and another quote
the one is outside nothing but it has
intercourse with all things
indeed this apathetic way of talking
about the one of postulating that the
very fundamental aspect of reality
cannot be understood or grasped or
described in any kind of way would be
incredibly influential on the
theologians and philosophers of the
monotheistic religions so thinkers from
the Islamic Christian and Jewish
religions and so would play a major role
in the vocabulary and symbolism of the
theologies and mysticisms maybe of all
those religions in any case platinus
indicates that we can become the one to
be United with it it's something that is
exceedingly rare but it can be done by
the most accomplished of souls plutonis
himself has obviously had this
experience or should I say
non-experience in fact porphyry tells us
in his biography the platanists
experienced this highest state on four
occasions while he was with him quote so
it is that this Divine Diamond of a man
ascended in his thought to the first
Transcendent God many times traveling
the roads described by Plato and the
Symposium and to him appeared that God
who has neither shape nor form who has
his seat above intellect and every
intelligible thing I poor free now 67
years old once Junior this God and was
unified with him anyway the goal
appeared near platinus his aim or goal
was to be unified and to be present to
the god that is set over all things this
goal an Indescribable state of
perfection he achieved some four times
while I was with him
and when we read sections from the
anions that talk about this uniting with
the one it seems pretty clear that he's
speaking from first-hand experience
quote on actually ascending to this and
becoming this alone casting aside all
else what could we say about it except
that we are more than free and have more
than autonomy
who would connect us with chance events
either random or due to an accidental
attribute once we have become the true
life itself or having come to be in it
which contains nothing else but is just
itself
what is this encounter with the one like
well since the one cannot be described
in any way obviously to try to describe
what it is to be that one is equally
impossible it involves a total
disappearance of the self and everything
associated with it to be mystically
United with the Noose is one thing and
that is a very high achievement indeed
where we become what we already were but
it seems that even in that moment of
Union with the Oneness of the Noose the
place where everything is non-temporally
and without division the United person
still retains some kind of individuality
even though she has become pure knowing
knowing herself through a knowledge that
is herself Beyond any subject object
dichotomy there is still some kind of
individuality or rather there is still
something but when the person wishes to
achieve mystical Union with the one she
has to reach even beyond the noetic to
the total darkness and nothingness that
is the one
she has to completely shed any sense of
herself even the noetic until she is
utterly nothing when she is quote alone
with the alone quote it is just like
those who are sent to partake of the
Sacred religious rights where there are
acts of purification and the stripping
off of the cloaks they had worn before
they go inside naked one proceeds in the
ascent passing by all that is alien to
the god until one sees by oneself alone
that which is itself alone uncorrupted
simple and pure that upon which
everything depends and in relation to
which one looks and exists and lives and
thinks there can be nothing with the one
because the one is nothing it's no thing
in a sense we cannot Unite with the one
at all instead we shed everything until
we are nothing and in that nothing there
is only the one so we aren't the one the
one is simply itself it just is
so this uniting Unbecoming the one is
not an experience it cannot possibly be
an experience because there is nothing
there is no one to have an experience
and nothing to experience there's just
the one being what it is in its utter
apathetic Darkness quote perhaps one can
argue that one should not say one will
see and the thing seen if indeed one
should say that there are two things the
Seer and the scene and that both are not
one
this argument is indeed rash
for at the time of Union this seeing
self neither sees nor discerns nor
imagines two things but has in a way
become another and not oneself nor does
one belong to oneself in the
intelligible world one has come to
belong to the good and has become one
like a center touching a center point
and that is the absolute highest
achievement and experience or
non-experience that we can have and is
accompanied by a kind of absolute Bliss
at least in the moments after since when
you are the one you are not experiencing
anything including Bliss it is even
described in erotic ways with the person
being a lover seeking out her beloved
and passionate yearning which obviously
reminds us a lot of later expressions in
Traditions like Sufism so now we've kind
of made the whole journey we started
with the one and saw how reality
unfolded and flowed from this one all
the way down to our individual souls and
even matter itself although that is is a
very complicated topic as we saw
and now we've also made that Journey
back from the individual self to our
true home in the noetic world and even
in a kind of mystical Union with the one
itself the outgoing and in-going from
the one back to the one the inhaling and
exhaling of the breath to use the
language of the Sufi IBN Arabi but this
is an episode about neoplatonism after
all and we're really only focused on the
Tinus here he is a very significant
figure perhaps the most significant
figure in that tradition since he's
considered the kind of founder at least
the most important systematizer of that
particular school of thought but there
is of course a lot more to neoplatonism
than just platinus because while his
successors would look to him as a great
Authority and base their ideas on some
of the most General features of his
system the later neoplatonist would
Forge their own ways of looking at the
world in which they could sometimes
differ dramatically and fundamentally
from platinus he was succeeded by people
like porphery who was a close student
who we've already met and and this guy
kind of stuck pretty close to the
teachings of his master
he was though a little more interested
in what we could call religion
so platanus in general used language
that wasn't really outright religious at
all I'm sure he believed in the Gods in
some way and he does refer to the newest
and sometimes the one as God or Theos in
singular but he doesn't really seem
bothered with fitting the religious
system of his culture into his
philosophy indeed we saw in the
biography that he even thought that the
gods should come to him rather than the
other way around
porphyry his student was a little more
interested in mythology and religion and
Incorporated that somewhat more into his
thought but this religious aspect really
starts to flourish with the later
proponents of neoplatonism such as
eamblicus and proclus where these
thinkers there appeared what is known as
theology which is a complex topic of its
own but which tries to call upon the
gods through rituals often with the
purpose of elevating oneself
so unlike platinus who believe that we
are in the news and that we can make the
journey to Perfection on our own by
simply plunging into the depths of our
own being the theorist or theorgic
neoplatonists like iamblicus believe
that we actually needed the help of the
Gods to achieve this journey to the
higher worlds and he describes theoretic
rituals to achieve such a Salvation the
gods of the Greek and Roman Pantheon
were often seen as being
personifications of different aspects of
the nomadic world for instance and are
given a much more prominent role in the
thought of people like yanbicus and
proclus right so unlike the sinus who
keeps his philosophy sort of separates
some degree from from religion in that
sense even though of course he
uses words like God and it's obviously
influenced by by religious thought to
some degree
um people like yamlikers and procolors
incorporates the religious system much
more into near platonism uh the
different gods become different aspects
of the news sometimes the gods Zeus or
Jupiter in the Roman context is
identified with the news as a whole and
then all the different aspects of the
news are the other gods which are kind
of aspects of Zeus as the highest God so
they fit the pantheon and the religious
mythology into this new platonic system
in a very
kind of a neat and impressive way a lot
of the time in general the later
neoplatanists are a much more systematic
in their approach than the Tinus from
reading the Annie ads we can see that
platanis probably has a kind of system
in mind but it's very hard to make out
the details of this system because the
aniads are very difficult they are very
messy partly because of porphy's
ordering of the NS but also how they are
written in themselves are a lot more
they're not as clear and systematic
let's just say compared to someone like
proclus in his elements of theology
proclus presents a much more systematic
and elegant structure of the neoplatonic
worldview but in these systems we often
see a stark contrast to platinus
well the tennis system is relatively
simple he likes to identify various
aspects of reality with each other and
in a unified sense those of people like
yamlikas proclists and others are often
a lot more complex
whereas platinus had a very simple one
news Soul structure yamlikus argues for
various levels of the one as well as
multiple intellects or nooses the one
has three aspects for example and the
lowest aspects of the one is the highest
aspect of the news and then the news has
three aspects of its own and the lowest
part of that is and he just every part
of those parts has Parts in themselves
so he and practice for example really
builds the system into a much more
complex picture many more parts and
aspects whereas platinus himself kept it
very simple and unconsciously he
actually he very much criticized other
metaphysical systems that made
everything way too complex right he he
kept it very simple as a principle while
the later near platiness as we see had a
much different approach theirs is a
metaphysics that has a lot more parts
and parts that are much more independent
indeed most of the later near platonists
would reject platanus's idea of the
undescended self for example where as we
saw an aspect of the self is always in
the nose
these later thinkers instead arguing for
a reality where the different parts of
the world or of reality are much more
strictly separated from each other the
human aspect can never leave the human
realm as such because there is a much
more Stark border between the levels and
instead requires other means of
achieving ascended states such as
through the help of the Gods for example
through theoretic rituals so this
creates a pretty confusing picture while
the neoplatonists in general are seen as
belonging to a single school which goes
back to platinus and ultimately to Plato
there is a huge diversity in the
different ideas that individual members
of this school had as we saw in the
beginning calling it a school at all can
be problematic and it should probably
rather be seen as a kind of loose late
antique tendency within platonous
thought so how can we Define
neoplatanism at all well despite these
differences there are still a few things
that unify neoplatonism as a coherent
philosophy and which characterize it and
the later developments that it
influenced neoplatonism in general holds
the idea of the hypotheses the levels of
reality which generally follow the same
outline there is the one followed by the
news followed by the soul followed by
nature and the physical world while the
different thinkers would postulate
nuances to this various intellects or
steps along the way the general outline
is recurring in basically all of
neoplatonism similarly another recurring
theme is the apophatic nature of the one
or of the most fundamental aspect of
reality
the idea that the one is hidden in an
absolute darkness of Unknowing Beyond
understanding or explanation we also see
characteristics such as these different
realities emanating out from each other
that the one emanates the news which
emanates the soul and so on now as
metaphorical as this may be it is still
a key feature of this school as well as
much else of what we have talked about
here today so when you see these
features that I've just described in
later religious schools or philosophies
you'll be able to recognize them as very
characteristically neoplatonic because
indeed as we said in the beginning
neoplatonism has been one of the most
influential philosophical movements in
history that has played a key role in
the development of Christian Islamic and
Jewish Theology and mysticism as well as
influencing Western so terrorism
occultism
as I said in the beginning also all of
what we call Western thought in general
it influenced some of the earliest
Christian theologians such as dionysius
whose epiphatic theology expressed in
works like the mystical theology is
strongly proteinion and proclin in
nature this would influence some of the
great figures and teachings of the
Eastern Orthodox church and figures in
the west like Meister Eckhart and
Nicholas of kuza just to mention a few
in the Islamic world neoplatonism and
the works of platinus became one of the
defining factors in the tradition of Fel
Safa and Kalam and influence such
figures as ibnc representative razi and
the Sufi metaphysics of figures such as
IBN Arabi and abuhammad al-khazali
similarly in the Jewish World
neoplatonism played a major role in the
emergence of various forms of Jewish
philosophy and mysticism including of
course Kabbalah indeed that topic of
mysticism is significant because so much
of what we understand as mysticism can
be traced directly to neoplatonism from
the apathetic language that is used to
the emphasis on the soul stripping of
worldiness and returning to a pure world
of mind and to be mystically United with
the one at the core of reality it is
some of the most common language in the
history of quote-unquote mysticism even
if that word should be used carefully in
other words we owe a whole lot to these
guys and they're fascinating ideas and
that is why it's so amazing that we're
doing this large collaboration here on
YouTube my colleagues zebi from Seekers
of unity Dr Justin Sledge from esoterica
Dr Angela puka Angela Symposium Dana
trell from the modern hermeticist and
John viveki from his channel John
bervicky are all making videos about
neoplatonism and its influence and
relationship with different aspects of
of intellectual history so be sure to
check out all of those amazing episodes
I'll be making two of them Xavi is
making three I believe my next video in
particular is going to be about
neoplatonism and Islamic thought so stay
tuned for that which should be coming
out next week but also definitely check
out the other videos or episodes they're
going to be amazing I've seen the the
episodes and they're absolutely
incredible I'm so happy and honored to
be part of this incredible project to
bring one of the most influential and
important philosophical traditions uh to
a wider audience here on YouTube again
I'm truly honored and so great to call
these people my colleagues and as also
my friends and I look forward to much
more similar many such similar projects
and collaborations in the future for now
this will have to do for an admittedly
inadequate and incomplete introduction
to the vast world of neoplatonism we
have focused primarily on platinus here
who is the perhaps the central figure
but we've also seen how this school and
this tradition is much broader than that
we've also touched on some of the other
significant thinkers from that school
still we've been introduced to some of
the core features and most important
aspects and tendencies of this amazing
philosophical tradition which will help
us better spot the places where it shows
it's a beautiful face in the history of
intellectual thoughts and even today
I'll see you next time
[Music]